[Musik]
ja ja ja
halle wegen gleicher video ist es
jugendliche auf den abiturball wo ich
eigentlich auch hinter abitur machen
sollen aber ich bin kleben geblieben per
gesten satz ich hab natürlich bis zum
ende durchgehalten haben der auf einer
toilette aufgebracht von alkohol ist
nicht gut
leider ist es so lebensbegleiter bei uns
sind gerade gefühlte 50 grad bei euch
auch da wo lebt nachdem sagen wir
irgendeine komplette scheiße hier
gelagert hat
möchtet ihr euch erst mal ganz ganz
herzlich begrüßen zu einem erneuten blog
auf einem kanal meine damen und herren
den heutigen video bisschen glocke
werdet ihr euch verschiedene arten von
beziehungen vorstellen aber erstmal
gehen wir was es heißt auf install
official laser luca alter geil alle
folgen der pizza bäckerin nimmst du
unsere stellung auf also ich nehme eine
große pizza tonno du nimmst die spargel
pizza ist einfach komplett überfordert
mit der fähre in sachen und pizza
schieren auch mit jule was tue ich bin
wirklich nett dass ein so krass fiel kam
es mit dem was neues ausprobieren weil
wie so oft da und ich habe mittlerweile
einfach schon weg aus dem trias ich kann
mittlerweile wirklich gar nicht mehr
richtig ab sehe was ich alles treffen
geben gesundheit was sich alle schon
sitzen gegessen habe also erhalten
natürlich für ganzen standard sachen in
die salami margherita herbei und
irgendwie sowas alles aber jetzt auch so
sachen die wir nutzen die ganze welt
würden aber auch immer dreht so richtig
krasse sachen wie beispielsweise
sonnenham abschenken
so oder so ein schweinebraten oder ihm
sogar dass ich bin dort super zu sehen
neben diesen schweinebraten und dann
kann man irgendwie auch mit spannenden
und dann aber noch vom trüffelöl oder
jetzt gerade hast du eine pizza geht
jetzt mit nudeln wir sind halt die ganze
zeit am überlegen was man besser machen
könnte weil wenn man eine mit schinken
macht dann sind alle vegetarier sei aber
wenn man wieder normal gar nicht am 8
das ist zu wenig wenn man eine
vegetarische pizza macht dann kommen
alle an und sagen hey ya wenn der
schinken drauf wäre damit auch viel
geiler oder salami oder irgendwie so
also freunde schreiben einmal in die
kommentare bitte was würdet ihr am
liebsten auf einer pizza drauf haben
aber jetzt würde ich sagen stellen wir
euch erst mal zehn verschiedene arten
von beziehungen vor
[Musik]
ich liebe sport zu machen
sie können zusammen an unseren körpern
arbeiten komme ich mache meine schlutter
hoch wir sind ein herz und eine seele
wenn wir trainieren
aber wir können zusammen auf dem
gleichen gerät sport machen das ist wie
gemacht für uns für ein richtiges
dienstag fitness workouts das muss viel
trainieren
da geht man herrn braucht
[Musik]
ein bisschen kicken
[Applaus]
[Musik]
kevin hat gerade geschrieben scheint die
du darfst nicht antworten jetzt
natürlich ist es ist es eigentlich ein
klasse
[Musik]
hast du ihn geschrieben wir sind wieder
zusammen
[Musik]
spürst du das chakra durch deinen körper
fließen ich werde eins mit dem raum
werde eins mit dir meine liebe liebe
liebe lebt bei liebe zu dir die energie
fließt durch meinen körper sie soll
darüber wie in teilen körper bleibe in
meinem körper mit energie einzelne dem
raum drei wochen gesehen am stück und
jetzt wo es wieder bergauf stadtteil wir
bekommen das in kamien gehen dann werden
wir auch mal nebeneinander sitzen können
und jeden tag ashanti ich weiß ich weiß
wir finden die irgendwann mal eine
lösung ich verspreche ich kämpfe ja
hoffentlich weiß nicht wie lange ich das
noch kann ich erhebe dich einfach so so
sehr ich kann keine sekunde getrennt von
mir sein anteil ich muss jetzt darauf
legen wir sehen uns in fünf jahren vier
tage ich liebe dich auch und zehn
sekunden
ok dann legt jetzt mal aufstand nein du
weißt ich kann das nicht gelebt ich
glaube ich die mal kurz auf
[Musik]
juli dann sagst dass solche liste
behinderten ein café gaul zeitgleich
kapiere ich habe folgende machen dass in
den bau gesteckt capitol hashtag vor
etwa klar verstecken und shanti hashtag
baby ist glatt nochmal weil uns
unendlich sind 2001 versteckt juli
hashtag bizeps und fotos online haben
[Musik]
das bereitet auch ich hatte sie ich habe
ja exakt herzen vorbereitet deine haare
grenze sowie das herzen ich mag sich so
gern ich im amt bin ich bin ich ja das
ist meine freundin judo darf in den
anderen leuten reden wir doch schon ein
bisschen zu lange
hört mal auf geht nach hause
[Musik]
wie fandet ihr die zehn verschiedenen
arten von beziehungen freunde welche
beziehung ist vielleicht eure gewesen
überhaupt dabei ab überhaupt eine
beziehung
ich möchte euch noch ein neues inhalt
lockstoff denke wir haben auch immer
keinen namen dafür gefunden und zwar
habe ich mir gedacht da er so
unmenschlich viele kommentare unter dem
blog gepostet werden ich beantworte
kommentare
[Musik]
es ist einfach gut mein fehler sorry
wenn die frage schon beantwortet wurde
aber mit welcher app hat jude die bilder
bearbeitet also wenn es um diese bilder
hier gingen die wir für das instagram
account erstellen video gemacht haben
die hast du mit snapshot mit snapshot
bearbeitet redet ihr beiden euch jetzt
auch einen hund anschaffen der juli also
gerne einen haben will oder klappt das
nicht wegen arbeit und so dass hier
eigentlich so unser aller lieblings hund
also einen golden retriever in der farbe
und die sache ist halt wir hätten beide
unglaublich gern hund nur ich bin halt
leider mega viel unterwegs immer und ich
finde wenn ich mir ein rund hole dann
soll der hund auch der glücklichste und
der welt sein und dann möchte man halt
auch ein garten haben weil in meiner
wohnung in köln wird der glaube ich
nicht glücklich sein aber früher oder
später uns helfen rund als wenn nun im
hintergrund der songs hab gedacht wie
immer nach dem kauf benutzt ihr es nicht
mehr ich habe das auch erst gedacht
allerdings sind juden ich wirklich
eigentlich nahezu die ganze zeit am
nintendogs spielen oder am pokémon oder
irgendwie so das macht schon echt krass
viel spaß ich werde dich finden und
knuddeln
okay die heiße latina grund lied ich
weiß nicht was 100 grund liegt es aber
falls sie das hintergrund lief mainz das
ist irgendein lied von epigenomics ist
eine riesige library und darauf waren
habe ich dann verschiedene spuren
genommen also das genaue lied findet man
so eigentlich wirklich nicht klappen
bekommst du viel geld aber gibt es
weniger aus wie youtube es kleinere
youtube sowie das sich nicht so viel
geld ausgeben also natürlich kann wenn
man ein kleinerer youtuber ist und man
verdient sein erstes geld mit youtube
investiert natürlich eher indirekt mal
eine neue kamera und keine ahnung was
habe ich bin mit meinem kompletten
equipment zufrieden und ich weiß nicht
was ich dann irgendwie noch großartig
krass viel geld ausgeben soll ich könnte
jetzt natürlich oder 30.000 euro red
kamera kaufen und keine ahnung was aber
hey ich meine schaut euch meine qualität
der blogs an dafür das kann ich auch mit
meinen alten nokia auf dem partner hat
mit julia heß mal locker ford leid
hättet ihr mal bock darauf dass jule
fordert spielt schreibt seine kommentare
freuen und eventuell kommt dann
mit jule das den bart wachsen damit
würde ich kommentare beantworten
an dieser stelle auch beenden an der
stelle durch den kompletten block jetzt
allerdings auch beenden freunde mir hat
sehr viel spaß gemacht ich hoffe euch
hat das video auf gefällt mir die zähne
arten von beziehungen sollten wir das
ganze eventuell noch mal mit einem
anderen themengebiet machen also
vielleicht mit zehn arten von
vollidioten oder so lasse ich mich gerne
in den kommentaren wissen freunde lasst
eine leica und jude euch nur was sagen
die letzten drei worte
[Musik]